quand j'ai appris que j'avais tiré au
sort pour la convention citoyenne
y pas vraiment mais sachant que je ne
savais pas vraiment ce que c'était la
convention citoyenne
il m'a fallu un petit peu d'explications
avant de comprendre ce qui se passait et
ce que c'était et puis que c'était vrai
pas une blague et puis
et puis enfin accepté que c'était en
fait une super opportunité une chance
assez inouï
je me suis dit qu'ils m'appellent c'est
une arnaque
jpg pouviez pas cru voilà tout
simplement et ensuite j ai cru quand
j'ai vu le billet d'avion pour venir je
me suis même dit jusqu'au bout avant de
rentrer dans l'avion le billet va pas
passer c'est un faux billets soit
possible c'était vraiment une très
grosse surprise et quand j'ai commencé à
réaliser qu'en fait non ce n'était pas
une blague c'était quelque chose de réel
une totalement nouveau et inédit dans la
france pas j'ai commencé à être très
impressionné je me suis dit est-ce que
je suis à la hauteur ou pas de pouvoir
participer à un tel projet et finalement
je me suis lancé gibbons et j'ai rien à
perdre j'ai tout à gagner j'y vais je me
lance
en fait on était en plein dans le
mouvement d'un gilet jaune en même temps
que dans le mouvement démarches pour le
climat et des grèves pour le climat des
jeunes et on voyait bien que la réponse
de l'exécutif était loin d'être à la
hauteur sur le volet démocratique et
donc on s'est dit avec tout un collectif
qui s'appelle léger les citoyens que
il fallait aller plus loin et qu'il
fallait lui proposer de faire une
assemblée citoyenne tirés au sort qui
puisse délibérer sur les grandes
questions qui nous semblait émerger de
ces mouvements la question climatique la
question démocratique et la question la
justice sociale
j'avais préparé un peu mon argumentaire
donc j'avais apporté les enquêtes et les
études scientifiques qui montrait la
gravité de la situation pendant 45
minutes j'ai raconté tous à emmanuel
macron et donc je lui dis je pense que
la seule solution pour parvenir à mettre
en oeuvre des mesures vraiment
ambitieuse pour le climat c'est que les
français se saisissent du problème
cirque eux-mêmes puisse
regarder quelle est la situation en
auditant des scientifiques consultant la
littérature qui a été faite sur le sujet
et que eux mêmes ensuite puisse
délibérer pour se dire quelle solution
n'est prêt à mettre en oeuvre qui serait
acceptable par tous et qui permettrait
d'atteindre nos objectifs donc je disais
pour faire ça l'idéal ce serait de faire
une assemblée de citoyens tirés au sort
sont représentatifs de toute la france
de les faire travailler pendant un
certain nombre de semaines en leur
donnant toute la matière qui est
nécessaire qui puisse auditionner des
scientifiques qui puisse auditionner des
parties prenantes de toute la société
qui formulent des propositions et que
ses propositions soient transmises
directement aux français pour référendum
et que tout ça se passe à ciel ouvert
pour que pendant que les 150 délibère
tous les français puissent savoir ce qui
se pressent ce qui se raconte dans cette
assemblée puisse avoir ce même genre de
débat chez eux ou au bout au boulot gros
que la société française et le débat en
même temps que les 150 et que ça
continue pendant la campagne
référendaire c'était ça l'idée
pendant tout le déroulé du processus on
a été
extrêmement ému de voir à quel point les
gens qui venaient de tous ses horizons
différents était capable de s'approprier
cette thématique est quand même
extrêmement complexe ils viennent
vraiment pour résoudre le problème ils
viennent pas pour eux ils viennent pas
parce qu'ils ont un intérêt particulier
ils viennent parce que c'est l'intérêt
de tout ce qu'on fasse quelque chose
pour le changement climatique c'était
bouleversant pour nous parce qu'on on
connaît ça on a déjà on est déjà passé
par tout ça mais eux c'est comme s'ils
arrivaient et on s'est rendu compte à
quel point il y avait plein de français
qui devait être dans la même
dans le même état d'esprit c'est qu'ils
se rendaient juste pas compte et donc ça
nous permettait de voir que le problème
démocratique il est là à dire que si on
n'a pas la possibilité tous ensemble de
prendre conscience de la situation sert
de se mettre d'accord sur le problème là
c'est impossible de se mettre d'accord
sur les solutions à apporter
[Musique]
la première session était
comment dire
dur
on a appris des choses on a assimilé des
informations qui en fait c'est un coup
de matraque
je savais qu'il y avait des choses qui
n'allaient pas au niveau du climat qui
avait
que ça n'allait pas mais là on a eu
toutes les informations qui nous ont
vraiment assommés en fait qui ont fait
peur mais qui nous ont aussi ou qui
m'ont conforté dans le sens où je devais
faire quelque chose
et aller jusqu'au bout
bah ce que j'avais vu du changement
climatique ça se résumait à un du tout
et à rien du tout est
vraiment rien de bon pour pas vous
cacher je me jeter plein de trucs
partager tout jugement je m'en fichais
mais depuis depuis que j'ai vu un peu on
a été beaucoup en fait j'ai 3 pour les
trois premières des trois premières
phases de la de la convention ils nous
ont beaucoup
beaucoup renseigné on n'a pas l'air à
des chercheurs on a eu des présentations
des diaporamas plein de trucs les
documents et où on a pu se renseigner et
là j'ai compris j'ai compris qu'on était
vraiment dans la faim dans une mauvaise
posture
voilà avant cette convention j'avais pas
une
une vision approfondie sur le
réchauffement climatique
j'en attendais par les musées
c'est pas bon
mais lala com a fait toucher du doigt de
qu'on m'a donné les moyens de comprendre
ce que c'était quand matt on m'a dit on
ne peut utiliser tels moyens pour lutter
contre la wii je me suis je suis
clairement impliqué et mis de dakwa et
demain j'essaierai d'avoir le
comportement et la réflexion
que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est à dire de de
lutter à maximum contre le réchauffement
climatique depuis ma participation à la
con citoyens j'ai remis en question
beaucoup de choses dans ma vie je
travaillais à à 5 km de mon domicile et
j'y allais tous les jours en voiture
donc dès le premier week-end j'ai
complètement arrêté d'utiliser ma
voiture je fais tout vent vélo
j'ai je suis devenu végétarien j'ai
changé de travail
je voulais je voulais je travaillais
pour g j'ai pas changer de métier mais
j'ai mais je travaille pour un projet
qui qui qui contribue à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et et
en fait c'est devenu tout ça c'est
devenu une évidence pour moi tous ces
choix que j'ai faits qui sont pourtant
super important mais que j'ai fait sans
aucune difficulté
[Musique]
e
pendant la convention citoyenne il ya
des intervenants qui venait pour nous
aider à rédiger les pistes de mesures on
avait commencé à envisager et c'est
comme ça que mon associé a été invité
pour nous parler de son application
qu'il avait créé et j'ai trouvé ça
génial
et on s'est rendu compte qu'on a été les
lois tous les deux et qu'on travaillait
dans le même un cul batteur donc là même
le même endroit où naissent des projets
entrepreneuriaux et de start up à lille
et du coup on a continué à se voir
discuter je vais parler de la convention
citoyenne et s est naturellement on sait
on s'est associé dans ce projet
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on veut
mettre en fait les données
environnementales dans les mains des
industriels et des consommateurs pour qu
en fait l'impact environnemental ça
devienne quelque chose de rationnel
comme peut l'être un prix ya un an quand
on un industriel qu'on soit un produit
il va calculer tous ses coups il à
savoir combien coûte tel ingrédient est
de savoir combien coûte le transport de
tels ingrédients et ça c'est très
rationnel et à la fin il a un coût mais
nous on voudrait que ce soit exactement
la même chose qui que ce soit très
accessible pour un industriel qui va
savoir exactement le coût
environnemental de tels modes de
transport le coût environnemental global
de tels ingrédients et à la fin le coût
environnemental du produit
par exemple sur une pizza rennes on se
rend compte que l'impact environnemental
de l'emballage c'est même pas quatre
pour cent en global donc c'est bien
d'innover sur cette partie là il ya des
choses à faire par contre ce n'est pas
là où on peut faire le plus d'efforts on
se rend compte que c'est finalement
c'est presque 50% de l'impact d'une
pizza rennes c'est sur le jambon donc si
l'industriel décide de supprimer le
jambon et de le remplacer par un autre
ingrédient qui pourrait quand même
rapporter ce petit goût de fumé est
resté une pizza rennes en fait il réduit
de 50% l'impact environnemental de son
produit la création cet outil il répond
complètement à une démesure de lagon
citoyenne qui est d'afficher un score
carbone sur l'ensemble des produits et
services d'ici 2024
déjà c'est quand même un gros engagement
du temps
à chaque fois tu partais tout le
week-end un petit peu avant et en fait
ils vont rentrer à la maison avec une
espèce de valises de sujets de dingue
avec des chiffres des uns et avec j'ai
rencontré un expert lui d'indy raconter
ça qu'ils venaient de l'avant avec les
risques côté un peu exclusive de la
source de l'info qui est hyper belle
idée et c'est pas n'importe quoi et qui
est pas facile à retranscrire en plus
parce que du coup à pau qui
qui était très curieuse et qui avait
envie de tout comprendre il avait du mal
à retranscrire exactement ce qui se
passe c'est quoi ce que du coup je
passais plus de temps à du cours faire
le week-end
avec la peau en fait et c'était c'était
pas mal c'est notre lot de l'est devenu
végétarien dont on a appris à cuisiner
floriane il ya eu une fois les
discussions et finalement en très peu de
temps sa
triste vie quoi c'est marrant pour moi
les mesures les plus structurants de la
convention citoyenne c'est toutes celles
qui sont liées l'éducation l'information
à 150 c est important mais c'est encore
plus important quand ils sont enfants
nous on peut aller encore plus loin on
prendre conscience de son impact de son
environnement et siens est-ce que c'est
génial qu'on sait rien
ah oui
oui de france fin en tout cas je veux
pas je vais pas je veux pas lui faire
faire un steak s'il a envie de manger de
la viande ses fins il a envie de manger
de la viande avec eux à wired ailleurs
que la maison une phrase qui veut des
cieux parce que
je veux pas dire que quand il faut tout
faux c'est tout un chacun fait ce qu'il
veut et c'est lui qui décidera s'il veut
être végétarien mais si c'est moi qui
fais à manger il frappait choupinette
viande quoi
voilà
j'aurai apprendre à cuisiner
différemment par exemple et là je vois
ziba 8 ce sera sa baisse donc s'il veut
aller plus loin que nous ça sera mieux
quoi
j'ai beaucoup changé avec l'expérience
je suis devenu un peu plus sur deux -
aujourd'hui je suis là devant vous en
train de parler avant cette convention
je n'aurais jamais pu accepter ce que je
suis très timide ça m'a donné de
l'assurance aussi beaucoup d'assurance
et surtout surtout j'ai appris
énormément dans ce domaine et d'autres
domaines en côtoyant toutes ces
personnes que j'aurais jamais rencontré
ça a été une expérience vraiment positif
dans dans tout dans tous ces domaines là
oui
pour moi le grand moment de cette
convention ça a été le débat qu'il ya eu
entre nous au sujet de la semaine des
vins des quatre jours c'est pas tant le
sujet qui est important c'est ce que ça
a généré il y as parfois dans la vie
comme ça des sujets qui entraîne et qui
engendre
l'intelligence et à cette occasion on a
eu
crescendo des arguments pour des
arguments contre et à chaque fois que on
avançait dans le débat c'est est une
une joute oratoire avec force de
conviction et une intelligence de groupe
une intelligence personnelle assez
incroyable et en fait on l'a tous vécu
en tout cas pour beaucoup avec
avec véritablement de la passion et on
offre qu'on est ressorti de ce débat on
était tous exalté exaltée de voir tous
ces gens qui qui qui pour beaucoup ne
prenez pas la parole qui s'exprimait et
qui en une phrase de phrases développer
un éclair de génie et de l'autre côté on
avait la répartie inverse avec encore
plus de conviction encore plus
intelligent c'était merveilleux entendre
et à vivre ça reste quelque chose de
pronos
la convention citoyenne à modifier ma
vision de la démocratie parce que
je suis venu pour voir mais j'étais très
très très très dubitative de l'exercice
je me suis dit on va mettre 150
personnes ensemble ça va se bagarrer
dans tous les sens ça va être impossible
au bout de trois sessions on abandonnera
et j'ai été agréablement surprise
surpris de voir que lorsqu'on met 150
personnes ou même dix ou quinze vingts
personnes 30 personnes face et on était
dans des groupes
on arrive à trouver des solutions on
arrive à réfléchir on arrive à
s'entendre on arrive à discuter
et ça ça m'a ça me choque ça change mon
regard sur la démocratie participative
et citoyenne
mais
ça c'est triste fin c'est triste parce
que je pense qu'on qu'on tourne une page
de l'histoire aussi avec cette
convention mais ça montre aussi que la
démocratie habituel et est en train de
faiblir et que une nouvelle forme de
démocratie est en train de naître et
qu'il faut laisser cette place à cette
démocratie tout simplement
rapprochez
vous êtes case se dire qu'on a la moitié
de ceux qui ceux qui se sont inscrits
qui sont venus 50% c'est bien
que ce soit au niveau des seniors au
niveau 2 du numérique on aura toujours
une sensibilité sur l'éducation à
l'environnement c'est le point principal
de l'association voilà qui était assez
étonnant c'est que tu étais déjà engagés
d'un point de vue social et
environnemental j'ai vu l'association
changé j'ai eu l'impression que tout
avait pris de l'ampleur et en est revenu
forcier avec plus d'idées peut-être avec
encore plus l'impression que les
citoyens pouvaient aussi agir c'est à
dire que que chaque personne trouvée
pouvait apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
et pouvait être acteur du changement
quelque part je pense que ce que ça m'a
apporté je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
le fait de pousser les autres dans leurs
retranchements en leur disant mais il
faut y avait quoi faut pas faux pas
parce que c'est pas parce qu'il ya un
obstacle à que tu vas bloqué devant dans
tu le souhaites tu le détruit et tu tues
tu fonces
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je ne suis pris dans la
tronche quand j'ai dans ce grand club
mais ouais on va ramasser pour les ma
quote c'est n'importe quoi cette journée
c'est pas une journée qu'il faut
ramasser mais tous les jours j'ai dit
oui mais c'est pas une journée qui est
voué à se répéter tous les ans moi je
suis je serai très fier si l'année
prochaine plus de tour 2009 des bas
parce que bon on a plus de déchets vous
mais c'est vraiment un moment symbolique
pour se dire voilà aujourd'hui on a
ramassé 20 tonnes de déchets à la
réunion ce qui est inadmissible parce
que c'est une aiguille dans une botte de
foin séparation
[Applaudissements]
ça fait soixante quatorze autres
74,8 l'équivalent du poids d'une
personne ainsi peu de temps à si peu de
monde dans un endroit où on est censé
pas trouvé grand chose quoi en fait
le sénat l'assemblée nationale ils se
sont dit un peu attention et 150 ça
devient comme un de nouveaux élus ils
savent yens nous concurrencer en entre
guillemets en gros mc rompt il son s'en
fout un peu de ce qu'on dit à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat il va
écouter 150 et puis basta coin voilà ce
qui enverrait faisons faire les lois
nous a pas beaucoup écouté voilà sur les
149 mesure s'il y en a une dizaine qui
sont appliqués à 100% c'est déjà bien
monsieur le premier ministre est-ce que
vous pouvez nous promettre nom du
gouvernement que l'ensemble de nos
mesures qui découleront de nos
réflexions seront appliquées transmise
sans restriction et sans filtre en
france métropolitaine et dans les
départements d'outre-mer non merci
je peux pas vous le promettre je peux
pas vous promettre que toutes vos
propositions vont être appliquées je
vous mentirais si je vous disais ça
c'est vrai qu'on avait discuté et
beaucoup de l'éducation sur
l'environnement c'est la seule mesure
qui est passée sans modification est
conquis elle m'a dit c'est bon c'est pas
ces sages et relaxant et
ça c'est ma plus grande fierté que ce
soit passé et de me dire un jour ben si
je travaille dans l'éducation nationale
ou même pente mais si j'y travaille pas
il faudrait dire s'agit contribuer j'ai
contribué au changement du code de
l'éducation et intégrer l'éducation de
l'environnement dans les établissements
[Rires]
voilà après faut que ce soit appliquée
mais bon là c'est autre chose
alors moi j'ai toujours été un peu
rebelle donc la mesure qui me tiennent
le plus à coeur le plus efficace pour
moi immédiatement ces lots 110% 30 elle
n'a pas été retenue en précise comme
préhensibles puisque les gilet jaune ne
voulait pas du 81 mais justement j'ai
fait l'essai ce week-end et 110 sur 300
kilomètres j'ai perdu 4 minutes aux 100
km donc 12 min pour 300 km donc qu'est
ce que c'est de perdre 12 minutes pour
pouvoir permettre de gagner des points
pour le climat je trouve que c'est ce
serait important de le remettre en place
sachant qu'elle peut être modifié dans
l'avenir mais immédiatement c'est une
efficace qui coûte pas grand chose
pour moi c'est alors que j'étais
totalement contre au début parce que je
pense effectivement que une fois de plus
ça l'embêté les salaires nuit les
joueurs et j'aime bien rouler sur
jimmy rouler des fois on fait davantage
du 110 haies qu'on fait pas d'excès de
vitesse aussi
donc celle là on tient quand même à
coeur c'est l'écocide la mesure sur
l'ecosite sur la protection de
l'environnement fin de la biodiversité
de tout de tout ça et de punir tout ceci
par du coup un crime déco side et de
mettre ce crime descossy dans la
constitution et du coup c'est exactement
là dessus qu'il faudrait partir c'était
limite la première mesure que le
gouvernement aurait dû mettre en place
et et tout ça et au final à au discours
de monsieur macron à l'elysée
comment dire il a mis de côté et enfin
il a mis de côté il avait ses trois
joker où il a refusé du coup les trois
mesures
controversées on va dire et comme on
dirait sur celle de l'écocide il a dit
qu'il allait à nouveau en reparler d'eux
à l'international mais qui pouvait pas
prendre cette initiative pour la france
le danger clairement nous on connaît
c'est la peur que des grandes
multinationales françaises fasse
attaquer du coup pour coup crime déco
side et qui pourrait du coup faire sans
aller ces sociétés mais
comment dire on est les premiers à avoir
fait les on a fait les droits de l'homme
faisons les droits du de la terre france
est un peu c'était un peu l'idée et
et du coup ça a pas été repris et je
suis un peu déçu on est tous un peu
déçus là dessus
disons que l'écologie c'est est une
thématique me tient à coeur et réduire
les impacts - 2 - 2 sachets moins d'eau
moins d'emballages c'était vraiment mon
truc à moi et ça le faisait beaucoup
rire quand je sais toujours de regarder
mes petites mais petit sac macha et
quand il a reçu l'appel effectivement
c'était c'est intéressant parce que je
me dis bah
peut-être le mettre le pied à l'étrier
ça va le faire savoir le voir les choses
différemment et finalement ça a bien
marché la convention citoyenne ce qui
est ce qu'il m'a apporté un degré
supplémentaire de réflexion
c'est tout ce carbone
qu'identité invisible au final mais qui
a un des effets réels
[Musique]
pour moi dans chaque action à la fois
dans le quotidien ou même dans le métier
c'est nécessité de savoir ce qu'on peut
faire pour le réduire au maximum et
contribuer à la sobriété carbone dans
notre domaine de compétence
larchitecture ça me semble enfin
extrêmement important dans le métier de
l'architecturé faut toujours avoir des
produits neufs c'est très compliqué au
départ on a toujours un grand projet oui
on va falloir rénovation va utiliser des
choses qui sont déjà été utilisé on a un
beau projet environnemental qui va
réduire l'impact ex thérapie finalement
on se retrouve avec un peu de pvc ici un
peu de place tôt que l'ade les silicones
du machin des trucs et finalement on
retrouve avec un projet qui a plein de
petits l'impact et a finalement assez
grande le fait d'avoir été appelé happé
par le parler climat ça a complètement
changé la façon de voir les choses et
pour moi il n'y a plus que ça qui compte
c'est à dire que dans toutes les
politiques qu'on doit amener ce soit
dans social que ce soit dans la santé il
faut qu'il ya un intrant climat qui soit
parce qu'en fait c'est la clé de voûte
de tout on n'a pas passé le cap de
d'expliquer à tout le monde le problème
c'est à dire contre est que les
conséquences et dans les médias on voit
que les conséquences on sait pas les
causes non lassus à la convention les
causes parce qu'on a vu des experts
première question que j'ai posée au
président d'une des premières fois où il
est venu nous rencontrer qu'est ce qui
ferait pour que nous ce qu'on a appris à
la convention citoyenne soit partagée à
67 millions de français jamais eu de
réponse à la convention citoyenne pour
le climat nous avons fait beaucoup de
rencontres lui beaucoup de rapports
d'experts nous avons appris beaucoup ces
informations ont été reçus par nous tous
comme un véritable choc elles sont
connues par tous les spécialistes par
tous les politiques partout le
gouvernement depuis des décennies mais
ne sont pas portés à l'esprit de plus de
66 millions de français des réseaux
sociaux comme twitter ça m'a beaucoup
aidé a touché beaucoup plus de monde je
réponds message répond sollicitations ce
week end je vais à quand une fois
j'étais à lyon enfin des choses comme ça
où il va l'entendre d'expérience de la
convention citoyenne
des signaux semblent ils avaient partie
105 ans
en leur transmettant sa il s'interroge
aussi sur la part que eux ils peuvent
apporter à cette histoire ça mais ça
donne faut donner de la personne ça vous
prend un exemple juste on avait fait une
mesure sur un malus lourd gouvernement
et cette mesure va changer juste le
barème la montée à 1800 kg
1800 kg c'était plus de 3% du marché
donc
c'est bien de prendre en compte
l'histoire mais à un moment il ya aussi
la question du curseur est curseur là il
a été décidé d' entre les ministères ça
devenait efficace toute la période de la
convention citoyenne des formidable de
rencontrer tous ces gens de discuter
avec d'élaborer le rapport se former sur
le plan humain je pense que je vivrai
jamais quelque chose d'aussi fort pour
au final après que ça devienne ça
devienne ça c'est
moi j'imagine tous ces gens qui nous ont
suivis aussi il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont suivi ça attentivement et qui
attendent encore aujourd'hui des
résultats là dessus dire que la loi
climat qu'ils ont rendus plusieurs
spécialistes se sont accordés à regarder
ils disent que on sera capable avec la
loi climat et les petites mesures à côté
france relance et c'est de réduire de 12
et demi pour cent les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on est très très loin du
mandat qui avaient été donnés de 40% non
je me suis très souvent posé la question
et je pense très sincèrement de me dire
que si j'avais fait le job j'aurais pas
été engagé en politique je pense
chanceux j'aurais pas continuer plus
loin c'est à dire que j'ai vraiment
sentiments en continuant comme ça de
montrer de façon
de façon de façon claire qui sont pas
allés assez loin et de montrer que les
citoyens on peut aller plus loin on peut
aller plus loin et devenir un exemple
dans ce cas là
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
annie ile-de-france ans la jeune great
attenberg pointe du doigt un pays comme
la france en dénonçant
comment dire un manque d'engagement ou
de réponse à certains accords la
question c'est quel est l'impact à cela
qu est ce qui finalement empêche la
france de pouvoir mettre en place des
accords qu'elle préconise elle même
[Musique]
mardi
c'est la bonne
les arbitrages auront pesé à plusieurs
titres
voilà du côté des citoyens
[Musique]
il me reste encore un carton mais tu
vois un carton c'est pratiquement trois
heures de boîtes âge
et en plus il faut bien connaître ton
orientation c'est un menu lâche les
fêtes c'est aller l'acheter et hop et et
tu reviens pas d'avoir un gigolo non
parce que je ne vois pas tout faire en
même temps c'est un peu un peu à son
envie tu sais pas encore si tu es mais
en fait hein tu prends quand même
vachement de ris parce que tu laisses
ton boulot 2 tu t'investis vraiment sur
cette campagne pas vraiment
et puis surtout tu vas au fond quoi tu
vas tu va discuter avec les gens tu es
petit tu es pas dans dans finalement le
discours dont on a intérêt sera il faut
voter écolo s'est tu raconte son
histoire
m'a moi du coup j'étais quand même assez
loin la politique et je le dis cette
défiance politique on a aujourd'hui
quand on voit même le niveau
d'abstention je comprends à un moment
donné c'est cette volonté s'est dit
lassé dynamique aussi que je que je veux
apporter s'est reconnecté à le citoyen
lambda à la politique et à travers mon
propre parcours mon témoignage à dire
que c'est possible de recréer un lien
avec nos institutions et la volonté la
parole citoyenne
ali
[Musique]
on a dit l'attentât
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
à noter que les écologistes ont
progressé en voix et en pourcentage
passant de 8 à 13% premier league en
tant que citoyenne lambda même citoyenne
en dehors de la convention c'est vrai
que j'ai découvert quand même une
compagne elle au rythme de la compagne
ce qu'on y fait c'est vrai qu'au début
je suis venu en disant ben moi je m'y
connais pas je suis novice je vous
écoute avec un peu d'humilité mais en
même temps c'est vrai que j'ai aussi un
j'ai aussi une certaine présence et je
pose des questions je m'intéresse et je
vais aussi bouger les lignes donc c'est
vrai que très vite je suis rentré à main
dans le jeu hein alors non je suis pas
déçu parce que franchement moi je suis
venu dans un esprit vraiment de soutien
à ce projet à sède assez dynamique et un
jusqu'au bout j'ai soutenu j'ai dit à
julien je soutiens c'est vrai qu'il m'a
dit dès le départ je veux vraiment avoir
une figure comme toi sur la liste
citoyenne donc voilà j'ai embarqué c'est
vrai mais un nom je pense qu'il ya
vraiment une dynamique s'est dessiné ce
soir et je soutiens toutes les
candidates et tous les candidats qui
seront demain élu voilà au conseil
régional vraiment
[Musique]
comme tous les françaises et les
français on trouve que cette fonction de
politique elle est abîmée on n'y croit
pas quand on m'a appelé je croyais pas
en emmanuel macron pas du tout puissant
en sortant d'ailleurs et disons qu'il ya
un moment on doit se dire qu'on crée
dans la rue ça suffit pas ou il ya un
moment il faut prendre le problème à
bras le corps et changer la politique
par soi même
[Musique]
c'est une
action
j'ai pas
jeu
oui cette expérience elle a changé ma
conception des traits citoyenne avant je
pensais que d'être citoyen c'est voter
régulièrement
y
être blessante de ne pas avoir d'
infractions et c est à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je sais que il faut aller
au delà il faut donner plus il faut
donner son temps
il faut
il faut essayer de réveiller les autres
qui sont comme moi avant qu'ils sont
bien dans leur coquille qui se repose
qui profite de petits plaisirs il faut
qu'on se réveille et qu'on se mobilise
icône réagissent ensemble
la convention le mal du tout donné envie
de faire de la politique d'abord parce
que je me rends compte que quand on est
au pouvoir on perd beaucoup de ces
valeurs et il ya plein de choses qui
sont difficiles à mettre en place mais
je pense que le milieu associatif il est
vraiment complémentaire de la politique
et c'est plutôt temps ça où j'aimerais
aller en fait
il ya autre chose que la politique fin
est en fait les assauts ils font de la
politique tout montrer la politique mais
je voudrais pas faire de la peau de
faire j'ai pas envie d'être élu j'ai pas
envie de devoir le pouvoir parce que je
pense justement que ce pouvoir il est
peut-être mal répartie et qui devait
plus partagée dans la société parce que
le système actuel
me satisfait pas en fait je me dis que
c'est pas dans un système comme ça où
chacun devra trouver sa place où les
citoyens pourront donner leur avis et
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien me dire
qu'un jour je pourrai faire partie de
ceux qui participent à la politique
parce que je pense qu'on l'a déjà fait
avec la convention et qu'on continue de
le faire avec les associations
non
[Musique]
moi ça va quand même donné un peu
d'espoir si on donne enfin la parole aux
citoyens et on va pouvoir peut-être
changer quelque chose même si c'est un
petit chose au moins ça sera fait et on
va pouvoir enfin lancer mais c'est vrai
que je te voir agir c'était plus
beaucoup plus réalisable pour nous de se
dire qu'on pouvait agir que enfin tu
vois voir ashton grand-père agir ou quoi
au fait
c'est ça et alors quand tu as vu
j'aurais assez politique un peu genre
d'affronter genre à répondre avoir du
répondant le mec qui m'a dit clairement
sur le plateau mademoiselle vous devriez
lire ce livre et je les regardais 16e et
monsieur louis et dont est donc là le
mec il m'a raté l'a fait ah bravo
bah quand même il serait temps qu'on me
convainque qu'on comprenne que nous
aussi on n'est pas bête non mais qu'est
ce que fait sérieux de pouvoir demander
à 150 citoyens tirés au sort qui font de
la formation pendant aux quatre fois
comment va arranger le livre vous
répondre et je vais répondre qu'en fait
on crée pas les mesures en fait les
mesures on les crée pas on se base sur
tous les rapports on se base surtout ça
nous les mesures on les a pas on n'est
justement pas des espèces des experts et
on doit être gelée lui
[Rires]
c'est bien mais c'est pas ces patients
parce que 10 c'est justement que nous on
n'est pas des experts et on n'a pas
vraiment mais c'est ce que me disait mon
grand-père en me disant mais en fait toi
qu'est ce que tu vas faire là-bas t'as
pas les mesures tu sais pas ce que tu
vas faire là-bas et hop enfin tu es pas
assez intelligente en gros pour faire ça
et je me suis dit mais non en fait on a
tellement de gens qui nous est derrière
avec les rapports d'experts avec tous
ces gens qui ont déjà trouvé des
solutions que c'est à nous de les donner
pour dire où on a décidé maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous faites ce sera ce
sera le mot de la fin je me suis pris
plein de claques dans la tête ou les
jeunes visaient à 17 ans le travailleur
est elle ou sa gueule c'est puma le
droit de parler parce que c'était par
rapport à notre âge mais c'est par avoir
ce monde c'est genre si tu sais tu peux
parler je pense qu'il ya la fin à la
grève jeudi deux légitimités derrière
nous s'est dit bao qu'ait eu peut-être
qu'ils lisent le gic depuis 40 ans mais
nous on peut lire levier que depuis
depuis trois ans on lit les rapports du
giec et c'est bon y'a un truc qui a
changé aussi c'est mon questionnement
pour devenir maman est en train
d'hésiter de faire un enfant et ça me
brise le coeur aurait littéralement
est-ce que plus tard je vais avoir ma
famille à moi avec mes enfants parce que
j'ai peur ben en fait qui est plus un
monde comme j'ai eu avec des animaux des
plantes des ça me briserait clair que
mes enfants il disait pas ça et que dans
la pollution qui on le voit il ya de
plus en plus de maladies à cause du
dérèglement climatique et tu crois que
ça c'est c'est plus mon kit a fait dire
merde et ce que je vais avoir des gosses
c'est ok la première fois qu'il m'a
qui m'a fait penser à ça c'est même toi
qui l'a évoqué qui était dit on est
vraiment il ya une nuit où je passais
way la moitié de ma vie à penser à ça je
suis beckum fin c'est ouf comment ça se
fait que aujourd'hui on est obligé de
réfléchir de est ce qu'on va faire des
gosses aient et puis parce qu'on a envie
mais pas utiles on m'a fait le plus peur
c'est de me dire mais c est louis
ce qui me fait penser à ça et mais juge
henri sinon jeu sinon tranquille genre
j'aurais continué match tranquille
j'aurais pu j'aurais bien dormi d'abord
parce que la ccsn moi pas du tout
dégoûté j'ai quand même une grande vague
d'espoir je me dis ouais il ya des trucs
à changer il faut y aller et tout mais
je pense que ça va prendre du temps et
je pense que mon engagement il risque de
se radicaliser
je suis forcément avec des groupes comme
externe sur un million des trucs comme
ça où on se dit oh il ya d'autres choses
à faire et peut-être que ben juste
parler des députés ça sert à rien et je
pense que ma manière de manger elle va
surtout évolué dans cette manière là à
me dire j'ai envie de continuer de
parler aux gens comme ce que je fais
avec la convention quand je lui ai eu
dans des tiers lieux quand je rencontre
les gens sur le terrain boudiba c'est
très cool si on peut mettre en place il
ya des vraies alternatives et que ça
change vraiment
changer modifier les comportements de
certains dans notre entourage c'est
c'est pas quelque chose de simple il ça
se mesure dans le temps je crois
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya des
choses que l'on annonce ceux qui sont
marquantes quand on explique que si rien
n'est fait qu'à la fin de ceux-ci avec
la moitié de la surface tenait ce n'est
plus habitable les gens sont
relativement surpris et savent pas qu à
néant donc ça les marques très
profondément quand on leur explique ont
détruit un département par tous les deux
ans en artificialisation artificialisés
dans les sols pardon pareil c'est
marquant et en même temps on est tous
réfractaires au changement c'est humain
c'est dans notre nature c'est que on
aime bien certains quotidiens et quand
il faut changer radicalement de modèle
sociétal ou de mode de vie ou ont
révolutionné un peu son confort c'est
plus compliqué ou de beast est content
très très compliqué avec mes amis parce
que voilà c'est dit il me disait que
déjà la planète c'est foutu on peut rien
faire et moi je me disais tous aussi il
ya quelque chose à faire et l'avenir ça
nous appartient ça appartient à nos
enfants et à nos petits-enfants là il
faudrait qu on essaie d'agir faire le
maximum c'est qu'on préfère prêts au
pire mais petit à petit
je finis par me comprendre
ils m'ont donné leur coup de pouce à
chaque fois que j'ai participé à la
convention ils sont là quand j'aurai via
ces mêmes qui vient vers moi pour les
parler ce qui s'est passé vraiment et je
suis moi aussi c'était pareil je parlais
sont autour de moi dans ma famille
c'était vraiment c'est une fierté pour
moi
tous concernant moi j'ai pu observer
quand même une transformation qui est
une transformation quand même pas
radical mais avant été sensibilisés sur
ces questions là mais bon voilà c'était
d'un point de vue toi-même centré sur
toi-même sur comment tu vis au quotidien
que c'était aujourd'hui tu es plus même
mathieu ganio même oui pour m
mais finalement on a envie de le suivre
et de faire de faire comme lui de
réfléchir aux dangers à ce qui va nous
arriver effectivement temps en temps je
suis un peu dans la provoc avec
certaines personnes pour bousculer un
peu mais ça fonctionne dès fois et puis
des fois c'est bien c'est un autre
discours qu'il faut amener là je sais
que sa venue en ce moment mon truc c'est
à dire très bien vous m'affirmer des
choses quelles sont vos sources j'ai vu
sur internet internet c'est pas une
source internet c'est c'est le far west
dans ma classe au moins où je t'ai fait
intervenir il ya eu lieu avant ou tu
avais les mecs du fond de la classe qui
n'est pas là pour faire ça et une fois
que mathieu est passé et même une même
quand est reparti avec sont venus me
voir à kindia mais en fait ils l'avaient
dit ça il avait raison et puis ça faudra
en reparler puis sam achats et
finalement ils ont été peut-être sur 35
une quinzaine à faire leur oral de bach
parce que sur les 150 sur l'urgence
climatique est un mec que lambda et puis
il a regardé sur tintin nature il n'a
pas d'étiquette il a rien il arrive et
il parle de ça c'est ton voisin ton
cousin tard il arrive je suis là lance
nature c'est plus facile à comprendre si
c'est plus dans la stratégie
un temps donné des costards cravates qui
gêne que parler de ça à voir les mecs
lanza et l'air de rien comme ça et hop
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous
la convention citoyenne ses 150 citoyens
qui sont censés représenter les
territoires il y avait des gens qui
venaient de zones rurales de zones
périurbaines et de zones urbaines on
n'était absolument pas forcément
concernés par les enjeux climatiques la
vérité c'est vous qui la détenaient
c'est vous qui pouvez la construire donc
s'il vous plaît emparez vous de ce sujet
ne laissait pas des genres décidé bon
goût c'est d'aimer reprises de positions
qui sont complètement différentes je le
dis assez souvent mais je pense que
c'est important moi je rentre dans la
catégorie des gens qui ne sont non
diplômés et quand on est diplômé de
temps en temps on ne dit rien on reste
de côté parce qu on part du principe
qu'on n'est pas suffisamment éduqués ou
ou et on se prononce pas parce qu'on se
dit bon ce que je vais dire c'est pas
forcément intelligent et en fait non ça
ça y est c'est un verrou qui a
complètement sauté prend des positions
qui sont réfléchies et je sais que ça
peut avoir aussi du poids et que ça peut
servir à quelque chose je pense que
c'est un peu un moment où nous on s'est
un petit peu dit ok c'est bon maintenant
on s'approprie le sujet et on va écouter
les experts mais on va en faire ce qu'on
veut
amiens la tournée des tirs lui en fait
elle vient d'un moment de rencontre au
grand voisin on s'est aperçu que les
objectifs et le projet de la convention
était complètement en accord avec le
principe d'être sérieux et on a convenu
comme ça un petit peu sur un pari de
dire bah venez on essaye de lancer une
aura des rencontres citoyennes un peu
partout sur le territoire c'est
maintenant parce que six mois déjà je
commence à me poser la question de ce
que je vais pouvoir avoir des enfants
juste parce que je sais pas de quoi le
monde sera fait demain c'est pas normal
alors je compte vraiment sur vous ça va
pas le faire l'après convention il se
décline en plusieurs phases pour moi en
tout cas j'ai réussi à obtenir un poste
dans la ville où je travaille qui est
directement en lien avec le
développement durable la transition et
puis après je m'attendais à ce que ça
retombe un petit peu et en fait je
m'aperçois que non on est sollicité
encore par les collectivités qui veulent
développer des conventions citoyenne et
qui nous appellent pour pouvoir les
accompagner dans certains projets je
pense notamment une convention dans une
communauté d'agglo du 93 ou là on va
pouvoir réellement confrontés la fin du
mois et la fin du monde et qui va être
la petite soeur de notre convention je
me présente rapidement je m'appelle
mathieu et je suis passé par les mêmes
étapes que vous avez jusqu'à présent
j'étais membre de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat au niveau
national donc il ya deux ans de ça j'ai
été tiré au sort et j'ai participé à une
expérience qui ressemble à la vôtre
l'expérience de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat c'était une expérience
très enrichissante et passionnante
beaucoup d'observateurs ont reconnu le
sérieux de nos travaux et de nos mesures
ces mesures elles ont été construites
grâce à nos différentes expériences de
vie
très vite nous avons compris que chacun
d'entre nous nous pouvions amener notre
pierre
on est tous super jammes le message que
j'ai pour les 150 c'est que moi je suis
super fier d'avoir fait partie c'est
rien
c'est
c'est autant une
une france de poche comme on disait que
c'est l'équipe de france de foot c'est
c'est tout ça c'est un feu d'artifice
c'est le 14 juillet c'est c'est ça les
150 cd tarte aux pommes autant que
des gens qui qui
t'est des français il parle de bouffe et
politiques et donc ça c'est c'est génial
et on t'as pas envie que ça s'arrête
et
évidemment qu'on même dans les pires
moments de doute où c'est difficile de
d'entendre parler de tous les matins de
ce que de ce qu'a fait tout ce qu'on a
fait à la radio mais à la radio et dans
la presse ou deux qu'on nous regarde
qu'on nous critiquons ce fait on se fait
marcher dessus par moments il ya cet
esprit de corps qu'elle est super
intense où il y en a pas un qui qui se
fait lâcher par le même s'il ya des
mauvaises langues et on se tape dessus à
des moments au moment où faut être
solide et face à des situations où face
à aux gouvernements aux face à
une unité qui est
et qui est vraiment impressionnante et
une solidité qui est bien bien au delà
de ce qu'ils pouvaient être attendus et
moi ça me rend très fier d'en faire
partie
mais tous comme vous on a tous
citoyens comme vous on n'est pas plus on
n'est pas moi c'est pas là pour le coup
je vais parler de moi c'est moi qui
était sélectionnée donc du coup ça
aurait pu être vous et ces mesures qu'on
a prises
c'est pas pour c'est pas pour vous
embêter c'est pour ces pour vous sauver
tout simplement
mais extrêmement positive dans cet
exercice c'est qu'ils aient eu lieu
qu'ils aient fait la preuve que la
démocratie délibérative ça marche que
quand on donne à 150 personnes
représentatif de toute la population
française les moyens de se faire une
idée du problème et de proposer des
solutions ils vont plus loin que ce que
tous les gouvernements font depuis 30
ans ça pour moi c'est une immense
victoire
on n'a jamais vu un exercice citoyen
déclencher une telle production
législative et réglementaire et ça a
permis qu'on ait une loi climat qui est
largement insuffisante mais qui malgré
tout est meilleur que si on n'avait rien
donc ça c'est quand même une victoire
que les citoyens de la convention et que
le mouvement climat qui a participé à
faire émerger cet exercice doit pouvoir
s'attribuer le premier moment pour nous
qui a été assez difficile c'est le vote
des propositions et le fait que dans
leur grande majorité des citoyens aient
décidé de ne pas soumettre des
propositions au référendum ça a été très
violent qu est-ce qu on les entendait
dire des trucs qu'on avait l'impression
d'entendre les élus qui parlait des
citoyens avant que la convention des
mains il s'était mis dans une posture
kaki qui ressemblait étrangement à celle
des élus en dix ans mais nous on a une
formation mais les français n'ont ils
vont pas comprendre et donc ils vont mal
voté
et donc évidemment nous on pouvait rien
lors des 1 et donc j'ai eu une
conversation avec une fois que le vote
étaient terminés en leur disant waouh
puis vous rendez compte que vous avez
choisi c'est là que vous vous êtes dit
que c'était plus sûr d'envoyer les
propositions à l'assemblée nationale que
au référendum alors qu'à l'assemblée
nationale depuis 30 ans les députés ne
votent pas les mesures qu'il faudrait
pour que l'on résolve à la crise
climatique
donc pour moi la convention citoyenne
c'est le moyen de créer une brèche est
de montrer que d'autres modalités
démocratiques sont possibles et qu'on
pourrait avoir une sorte de démocratie
on continue qui permettent à la
population de prendre part aux décisions
publiques il faut que ce genre de
mécanisme s'institutionnalise et qu'on
ne soit pas dans la situation où on
était là où en fait emmanuel macron avec
pouvoir de vie ou de mort
si je devais retenir une chose c'est
que quand les gens se parlent ils
trouvent des solutions
que c'est possible en fait
ce que je retiens c'est que quand les
responsables politiques disent ça change
pas parce que les français sont pas
prêts ou qui veulent pas c'est faux
c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
pour
non
[Musique]